[Música]
hace nueve meses el presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro llegó al poder
con una promesa de cambio social desde
el primer gobierno de izquierda en la
historia del país una de sus más grandes
apuestas también se ha convertido en su
mayor dolor de cabeza la reforma de la
salud una propuesta que causó hace unos
meses la protesta de varios ministros
que terminaron reemplazados y que este
miércoles se llevó al pedido del
mandatario de una renuncia colectiva de
su ejecutivo y a dar por finalizada la
coalición del gobierno después de que
los partidos tradicionales a bordo de
esa coalición dijeron que votarían en
contra hoy el país amaneció con siete
nuevos ministros y la reforma de la
salud en suspenso vamos al análisis de
esta noticia sobre este país
latinoamericano Juan Carlos Andrés Arias
orjuela Elsa docente de la maestría de
comunicación política de la Universidad
externado de Colombia gracias a usted
Carlos y comenzó preguntándole si le
parece
Claro que sí cuénteme uno de los
nombramientos son más polémicos o fue el
del ministro de hacienda Ricardo Bonilla
investigado por desfalco y previamente
inhabilitado con la noticia cayó el peso
este y otros nombramientos como dejan al
gobierno
varias varias cosas para anotar
efectivamente hay una investigación
sobre el doctor Bonilla sin embargo Esa
esa investigación al igual que la
investigación que le hicieron a Gustavo
Petro en su momento precluyó es decir su
inhabilidad hoy no está vigente está
circulando en varias redes sociales un
documento de la procuraduría general del
20 de septiembre 2022 pero ya es
fácilmente rebatible y con respecto a la
segunda observación claro efectivamente
hay una generar una inestabilidad en los
mercados con respecto al precio del peso
porque no habría otro ministro con tanta
relación y con tanta legitimidad frente
a los mercados internacionales y
agencias de de aseguramiento
internacional como José Antonio Campos
incluso él fue pieza clave y fundamental
en la reciente visita que hizo a los
Estados Unidos en la ciudad de Nueva
York con varias casas para para dar ese
ese Halo de seguridad y tranquilidad el
recambio
a pesar de que el doctor Bonilla pueda
llegar a tener un conocimiento técnico
que claramente si esta ideologizado pues
obviamente genera una preocupación en
algunos de los mercados ahora le
pregunto por el resto de ministros que
entraron en el abanico Cómo se
reposiciona el gobierno a partir de
estas modificaciones en que incluyen
además a la ministra de la salud o muy
polémica precisamente por impulsar esta
reforma que nos tiene o tiene más bien
al país en programado en el marco
legislativo
Mire las los recambios no como yo estoy
en desacuerdo para empezar por ahí mejor
estoy en desacuerdo en que se hable de
una crisis ministerial la crisis no es
ministerial porque nos dimos cuenta que
el cambio se hizo en menos de 48 horas
la crisis verdaderamente es una crisis
de institucionalidad y de coalición de
fuerzas políticas en el congreso que
como como equilibrio de poder es el que
termina avalando parte de las reformas y
parte de las propuestas del ejecutivo
que lidera Gustavo Petro esa crisis
política está básicamente representada
en una radicalización del discurso creo
que hay muchos analistas les incomoda la
palabra radicalización muchos analistas
de tendencia más de izquierda les
incomoda la palabra pero claramente si
uno ve uno a uno cada uno de los cambios
de los ministros ve ministros que o
trabajaron con el el hoy presidente
Petro en la alcaldía de Bogotá o
básicamente son personas que no tienen
un criterio técnico sino que tienen un
criterio político por ejemplo
lizcano que era el director del dapre
que era básicamente la la oficina que se
encarga de coordinar todos los aspectos
de de compras y políticos de la
presidencia de la República pasa el
Ministerio de tecnologías de la
información en la comunicación sin
ningún tipo de criterio técnico
simplemente pasa allí para seguir
teniendo una persona que es un Aliado
político que es un varón electoral en
cierta Región del país a un ministerio
el otro el otro ministro que no es
ideológicamente tan cercano a Gustavo
Petro Pues básicamente pasa la cartera
del Ministerio del interior porque fue
uno de los primeros congresistas que en
su momento se aliaron a la campaña de
Gustavo Petro este ministro que Luis
Fernando Velasco si tienen conocimiento
técnico y político de cómo funciona el
congreso Y seguramente va a ser un
Aliado importante para las otras cinco
reformas entonces lo que estamos viendo
Es
una digamos un cerco mucho más
ideológico hacia alrededor del
presidente es es un gabinete ministerial
que que básicamente es cercano a las
posiciones que siempre ha tenido Petro y
que lamentablemente no le va a poder
aportar mucho más de en una discusión
argumentada constructiva de discusión
incluso De oposición a Muchas de sus
reformas para cerrar creo que lo que
vemos en este nuevo gabinete
lastimosamente es un gabinete que que va
a ser un comité de aplausos en muchos
temas Claro pero precisamente la salida
de los ministros anteriores es porque
criticaron al gobierno porque criticaron
más específicamente la reforma de la
salud que que pues tampoco es poca cosa
no porque finalmente es una de las
apuestas claves que ha hecho este
gobierno en esta propuesta de de
llamarse el gobierno del cambio y de
traer una izquierda gobernante a
Colombia ahora le pregunto con la
ruptura de la coalición de gobierno y el
nombramiento de estos nuevos jefes de
cartera Qué podría pasar con la
disposición legislativa para esta
reforma de la salud y otras reformas que
tiene en camino el gobierno la coalición
de Gobierno ya finalizó con los cambios
de esta última jornada Pues que va a
pasar en el congreso al final Gustavo
Petro necesita abrir el camino para su
reforma
lo que va a suceder yo creo que se va a
hacer se van a se va a manejar en dos
ejes primero una negociación o una
ejercicio dialéctico para los más
esperanzados de discusión al menudeo Es
decir de discusión con facciones
disidentes de los partidos que
anteriormente conformaban la coalición
de gobierno facciones que hoy están
representadas en más o menos dieciocho
congresistas del partido liberal que se
han opuesto a la dirección histórica de
un líder que lleva muchos años en el
partido que es el expresidente César
Gaviria
disidentes del partido de la u y algunos
pocos disidentes también del partido
conservador entonces un eje va a ser una
negociación directa con ellos que
seguramente va a tener algunas
implicaciones burocráticas y otro eje va
a ser una recomposición de algunas de
las conversaciones y discusiones que se
tuvieron con algunos de esos partidos
que estaban en la coalición prueba de
ello es por ejemplo de nuevo retomando a
al doctor lizcano que tradicionalmente
ha estado en el partido de la u aunque
no desde digamos de de manera oficial en
en la nueva dirección que dirige la
doctora ilian Francisca toro pero que
está enmarcado en el partido de la u
entonces básicamente es una dádiva de de
si seguimos con ustedes pero no tan
fuerte Entonces yo creo que va a ir en
dos direcciones en esa disidencia de
negociar al menudeo y en una
reconstrucción que las bancadas que hoy
están en el gobierno Seguramente se van
a reformular y al interior muchos de
esos disidentes que hoy están
representados en el nuevo ministerio el
ministro del interior que ha sido una de
las de las aristas disidentes del
partido liberal seguramente van a pedir
el recambio de de la dirección liberal y
lo mismo puede llegar a suceder con el
partido de la u y el partido conservador
pero Habría que ver si eso llega a
suceder porque ha sido muy fuerte la
presencia del partido liberal de los
partidos tradicionales no solo en este
sino en los demás y para Gustavo Petro
ha sido una banda de negociación que ha
tenido que ir ampliando ampliando hasta
que bueno explotó y han sucedido estos
cambios en nueve meses de mandato
finalmente van dos crisis que podrían
ser para algunos calificados de
ministeriales para otros de crisis
política usted nos acaba de hablar de
crisis institucional pero ambas crisis
son por la reforma de la salud en ese
contexto usted qué diría de la
efectividad que hasta el momento ha
mostrado el gobierno en materia
legislativa
la pregunta Tiene muchas muchas aristas
y muchos enfoques Sí perdón es que
tenemos poco tiempo Entonces me toca
abarcar la mayor cantidad de tema
posible vale
a procurar intentar recogerlos desde una
desde una globalidad lo primero es que
El florero de llorente que es o el
símbolo de la Independencia y Colombia
que generó la revolución en florero de
gerente aquí es la reforma de la salud
pero más allá de la Reforma a la salud
hay que entender que este gobierno tiene
cinco reformas y un plan Nacional de
desarrollo que tiene que aprobar
rápidamente y este ejercicio de recambio
ministerial es una alternativa para
entrar a a hacer este ejercicio por qué
hablo de una crisis institucional porque
vamos ya para nueve meses estamos
aportes de cerrar el primer año y hoy lo
único que tenemos es lo que sucedió a
finales del año pasado es decir la
reforma política que se cayó y una
reforma tributaria que fue impulsada por
el hoy exministro campo que era uno de
los ministros con mayor favorabilidad
junto con Cecilia López de agricultura
sí esto también tiene que ver algo muy
importante y es que todos los estudios
de percepción recientes de todas las
firmas encuestadoras pagados por todas
las personas posibles o por todos los
gremios posibles muestran que Gustavo
Petro está perdiendo favorabilidad está
perdiendo impacto y la gente se está
alejando y está describiendo un poco de
lo que era el verdadero cambio y eso
básicamente va a afectar la agenda
legislativa entonces para cerrar ese
balance de agenda legislativa del 2023
es triste es débil sí porque tenemos una
un florero de gerente que no se
terminaba de cristalizar que pasó una
primera etapa primero una primera vuelta
pero falta llegar a plenaria y faltan
otras cuatro reformas que no se han
presentado y no sean no se han
presentado no no se han empezado a
discutir y un plan Nacional de
desarrollo que tiene que aprobarse
porque es la hoja de ruta y lo que va
entre comillas garantizar la
financiación de del cambio verdadero que
tiene que llegar a las regiones hoy lo
que se está percibiendo es un gobierno
que tiene muchas intenciones de cambio
quien quiera apoyarse en la opinión
Pública para apalancar ese cambio que en
el legislativo no se está logrando y que
básicamente se esté se está viendo
inactivo Claro pero es que como usted lo
dice muy bien la aprobación de Gustavo
Petro y de Francia Márquez esta mañana
se ha hecho un display de este tema en
los medios colombianos nos llega el 40%
están perdiendo Además del impulso
legislativo el impulso popular Cómo
podría Pues claro evidentemente en
medidas expectativas hay un castigo pero
pero cómo podría este gobierno recuperar
esa confianza pues que lo llevó al poder
muy rápidamente porque ya se nos acaba
el tiempo básicamente
entre comillas fácil que me ha hecho y
es que la única forma es entender que el
ejercicio de la política se hace en la
dialéctica y en la concertación y en la
discusión y en ceder para poder avanzar
Y eso es lo que más le cuesta al
gobierno de Gustavo Petro entonces si yo
pudiera recomendarlo algo al gobierno
Gustavo Petro es diálogo concertación y
entender que la política sin partidos
políticos fuertes es casi imposible y lo
que se está presentando en Colombia es
una desinstitucionalización de los
partidos en donde básicamente
al Amparo del Halo de que este el
gobierno del pueblo y que nos debemos al
pueblo y no va a entre comillas a
algunos políticos se están fracturando
los partidos y si se fracturan los
partidos
justamente tarde o temprano se termina
facturando facturando la democracia
Entonces el camino es diálogo No claro y
ya simplemente para hacer una rápida
conclusión porque efectivamente Nos
quedamos sin tiempo Qué difícil es traer
esta discusión a la mesa cuando estamos
hablando de un país latinoamericano que
toda su historia ha estado gobernado por
la derecha y de repente llega una manera
diferente a tratar de romper un montón
de estructuras pues que no se pueden
romper al menos no en cuatro años de
gobierno al menos no en la primera
intentona y y que necesitan como usted
dice mucho diálogo Yo le agradezco por
esta por esta conversación tan
constructiva es Carlos Andrés Arias
orjuela docente de la maestría de
comunicación política de la Universidad
de externado de Colombia que tenga un
feliz día Muchísimas gracias a ustedes
por por tan importantes aportes y sobre
todo tan importante reflexión Más allá
de del hecho político coyuntural que es
un recambio ministerial y más allá de
las posturas políticas gracias a usted a
nuestros televidentes sigan con nosotros
ella volvemos con más de directo a
América
[Música]